je suis très heureux que la confiance
unanime des administrateurs mais confié
cette fonction bénévole il faut le dire
tout de suite c'est une fonction
bénévole c'est une fonction importante
le chu c'est quoi centre hospitalier
universitaire nous allons bien soigner
les réunionnais c'est chose faite mais
il faut continuer à améliorer il fallait
tendre vers la perfection et nous allons
donner à cet hôpital les moyens pour
qu'il soit aussi un centre universitaire
et de recherche qui fasse honneur à la
france dans l'océan indien
aujourd'hui l'hôpital traverse une
situation financière difficile
nous sommes en déficit parce que nous
accomplissons des missions qui ne sont
pas compensés parce que nous avons
amélioré les normes en matière de
personnel et que nous attendons une
subvention d'équilibré
nous sommes en train de transformer le
pôle sud du centre hospitalier en un
pôle moderne en engageant plus de 110
millions de travaux tout ça est un
bouleversement qui correspond à la phase
2 du chu la phase 2 du chu c'est le cap
sur l'excellence c'est l'unité entre le
nord et le sud
il n'y a pas de préférence il ya unité
il ya complémentarité
il ya synergie avec l'objectif de la
qualité des eaux